vamos a realizar algunos ejercicios del
portal de khan academy que nos ayuden a
redondear las cantidades a sumar para
que sea mucho más fácil de hacer los
cálculos por ejemplo tenemos rellenar el
espacio tenemos 512 más 270 es lo mismo
que 500 más algo bueno que es lo que
tenemos que hacer aquí veo que pase del
512 al 500
entonces si aquí tuve que quitar 12 para
llegar al 500 que tengo que hacerle ese
12 para conservar la igualdad de mi suma
pues se lo tengo que agregar a este 270
270 más 12 me va a dar 282
porque hago esto pues porque me es mucho
más fácil hacer el cálculo de 500 más
282 que 512 más 270 que de entrada se
puede ver un poco complicado sin embargo
aquí si hago la suma de esto va a ser
500 más 282 tranquilamente en cálculo
que son 700 82 comprobamos respuestas
es correcta veamos otros ejemplos ahora
me dicen rellena el espacio 66 72 es lo
mismo que espacio vacío más 70 bueno si
veo aquí tengo un 70 y aquí tengo un 72
que tuve que hacer para pasar del 72 al
70 quitarle 2 quitarle estos dos para
conservar el valor de esta suma tengo
que agregarle esos dos que quite aquí al
66 al 66 le agrego 2 y me va a dar 68
esto lo hago porque me es más fácil
sumar 70 68 ya que esté 70 es un número
redondeado en mi mente es más fácil que
pueda ser la suma de un número así siete
decenas más seis decenas son trece
decenas que son 130 más ocho unidades
138 y ya tengo la suma de esto
veamos comprobemos la respuesta
es correcta hagamos otro problema más
este se ve más complicado pero no lo es
tanto
nos dicen completa para resolver 275 595
estas cantidades si se ven un poquito
más complicadas para sumar mentalmente
pero aquí lo que vamos a hacer es
resolverlas paso a paso
comenzamos con 275 más 595 después
pasamos a 270 más a algo mas 595 el 595
no ha cambiado aquí es el mismo pero el
275 si aquí ya tengo 270 que tengo que
hacerle al 275 para que me quede 270 le
tengo que quitar 5 entonces aquí separo
275 275 son 275 se conserva esto y esta
parte queda igual
ahora lo siguiente es que tengo igual al
270 pero ahora el 5 de acá tengo que
sumarlo al 595 por eso está en estos
paréntesis entonces aquí escribo mis 5 5
595 si hago la operación 595 5 me va a
dar 600 porque estoy haciendo esto qué
propósito tiene bueno si nos damos
cuenta al hacer esto es mucho más fácil
sumar 600 este número cerrado o
redondeado a cualquier otra cosa como al
270 si quiero hacerlo va a ser muy
sencillo en mi mente seis centenas más
dos centenas son ocho centenas y después
pongo estos setenta de aquí tal cual
ochocientos setenta y este cálculo fue
mucho más sencillo que hacer esta suma
así directamente que la verdad sólo la
podría resolver si agarro un pedazo de
papel y lo escribo para hacer la suma
tradicional
bueno comprobamos la respuesta es
correcta hagamos otro problema más
es un problema similar completa para
resolver 63 más 427 vamos a hacerlo paso
a paso
63 más 427 se está descomponiendo en 60
más algo más 427 427 no cambio el 63
pasó a 60 más algo y ese más algo para
que se conserve el valor de esta suma
tiene que ser este tres así que escribo
tres acá sesenta más tres más 427
después me piden que este valor de acá
que tengo que es un 3 ahora lo sume el
427 por eso tengo estos paréntesis
1060 se conserva igual hago la operación
y me queda 430 nuevamente es mucho más
fácil calcular estos números redondeados
que si los tengo así como está en el
problema original con unidades de
diferente valor y ahora sí cuánto es 430
más 60 escribo mis 4 centenas seis
decenas más tres decenas son nueve y no
tengo unidades 490 eso fue mucho más
rápido y directo de sumar que hacer esto
así comprobamos respuesta y es correcta